continuamos con la información aquí
entradas 24 y es tiempo de hablar de
economía estamos para eso montanier
hablando nuestra periodista que nos va a
contar lo más importante de dalián
empezamos hablando argentina que lanzó
una estrategia contra la creciente
inflación
liliana recordemos que este es uno de
los países de la región en los que más
rápido crecen los precios de la canasta
familiar para tratar de controlarlo el
gobierno creó un sistema que obliga a
que unas mil grandes empresas de los
sectores de construcción comercio e
industria informen mensualmente los
precios vigentes y cantidades vendidas
de todos sus bienes en las últimas
semanas de hecho el gobierno ha
sancionado a varias de ellas porque al
parecer están reteniendo sus volúmenes
de producción y esto hace que se suban
los precios artificialmente por eso cree
que con este sistema puede prevenir el
desabastecimiento y proteger los
derechos de los consumidores pero hay
quienes creen que no es así como este
analista que consultamos pero el
gobierno recurre a vieja fórmula que ya
han fracasado y que sólo sirven para
acumular presiones que terminan
estallando
tarde o temprano adhiero al hecho que
los precios no los marque de ganancias
se incrementan por los intermediarios
que hay en el medio de cualquier cadena
productiva que llega a la góndola del
supermercado pero esos intermediarios se
van eliminando con un mercado interno
más grande con competencia además de la
implementación de tecnología y mayor
productividad no con controles ridículos
o presiones explícitas a no aumentar los
precios
daniela y renunció el presidente del
banco más importante de brasil
estamos hablando de andré brandáo quien
será el presidente del banco de
operación hasta el primero de abril sin
cumplir siquiera un año en el cargo las
agencias atribuyen su salida a que el
propio presidente ya ir bolsonaro lo
venía presionando por sus planes de
reducción de costos en la entidad
controlada por el estado
el banco acaba de implementar un plan de
renuncias voluntarias efectivamente que
afecta a más de 5 mil de sus empleados
como parte de un programa más amplio de
reestructuración esta renuncia ocurre
apenas un mes después
evolucionar yo reemplazará a roberto
castelo branco quien era el director
ejecutivo de la estatal petrobras la
petrolera más grande del país a él lo
criticó en su momento por la fuerte alza
en el precio de los combustibles
daniela y chile tuvo su peor año
económico en cuatro décadas
liliana la quinta economía más grande de
la región fue la mejor librada después
de brasil en 2020 su contracción del 5,8
por ciento debido a la pandemia del cob
y 19 fue menor a la de otros países como
colombia méxico o argentina sin embargo
si hay que decir que es la peor caída
del producto interno bruto local en
cuatro décadas ni siquiera en la crisis
de 2009 la economía de este país tuvo
semejante descenso en ese momento ni
siquiera alcanzó el 2% el gobierno
reconoce que la recuperación que ha
tenido el país se debe entre otras cosas
a que el retiro anticipado del ahorro
pensional incentivo el ingreso y
asimismo el consumo de los hogares
daniela y la carne erre es importada de
estados unidos es cada vez más popular
en japonés
liliana y es tan apetecida que en apenas
dos meses los japoneses consumieron la
cuota máxima de carne con bajo arancel
de todo el año lo voy a explicar mejor
japón permite que anualmente entren al
país 242 mil toneladas de carne vacuna
desde eeuu con un gravamen especial del
25 8% pero si se supera ese umbral el
arancel se dispara al 38,5 y esa cifra
ya se superó con creces a comienzos de
este mes lo que quiere decir que sube el
arancel los límites de japón a las
importaciones de carne y otros productos
agrícolas han sido un problema comercial
recurrente con washington que importa
grandes cantidades de automóviles toyota
y videojuegos nintendo sin tanta
restricción por eso creen que hay cierto
desbalance también hay cuéntenos cómo
están los indicadores de esta jornada
wall street del cerro con pérdidas y el
más afectado fue su índice tecnológico
el nasdaq con más del 3 por ciento en
europa hubo cierto optimismo después de
los anuncios
la fed y en latinoamérica la bolsa de
sao paulo tuvo fuertes pérdidas tras
conocerse de esta renuncia y ahora la
cifra el diario/la con que no sorprende
hoy ileana mil millones de abonados
alcanzaron en conjunto las plataformas
de streaming en todo el mundo durante el
2020 debido a la pandemia en contraste a
este buen resultado la taquilla de los
cines cayó más del 70% bueno una
positiva y una negativa gracias daniela
por la información de colombia y usted
gracias continuar en france 24 punto com
[Música]